what's going on here in los angeles let  me tell you california governor gavin  newsom just released a  four-tier system to guide the state's  reopening  now los angeles is still in the bottom  tier  which means we have a long way to go  until things get back to normal  now some people still feel that governor  newsom is reopening california too  slowly and of course people on the other  side think his new system  is appropriate but i figure the easiest  way to tell  how things are in los angeles is just to  take a look outside  myself and judge what's going on  during this period of covid i'm going to  do that right now  best way to find out just check for  yourself  see how los angeles  is doing this will take a second  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  three  [Music]  a little more time a little more time  i don't frankly know where the tarantula  invasion came from  that surprised me